freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher kauft
ihr seht und ich bin heute bei max zwei
wechsel vor der kamera das heißt es wird
ein extrem gutes weniger maximal
neudörfl maximal gut und ich habe
gestern was meistens vorbereitet nämlich
einen chia pudding beziehungsweise einen
schier smoothie pudding max flüchtet
eigentlich nie und ich dachte mir kommt
dann gehe ich ihn trotzdem einen kleinen
gesunden snack um den tag zu starten
kann nämlich heute noch einiges vor wir
drehen auch für sebastian aber ihr seht
jetzt erst mal wie ich das ganze
zubereitet habe ich mache ja jiading und
der braucht bekanntlicherweise eine
nacht im kühlschrank ich zeige euch
jetzt was wir alles drauf wir benötigen
kokosmilch die mich mit ein bisschen
normaler nicht das ganze ein bisschen
voller ist dann brauchen wir natürlich
zusammen weil deshalb jahren dicksaft
zum süßen das hält wie das ganze und
toppings beziehungsweise eine base also
ich will das ganze so aufbauen unten
kommen referierte himbeeren rein dann
kommt ihr produkt und obendrauf kommt
man mit ein bisschen mandl einfach für
die textur sind auf jeden fall eine
serie von einer sehr lecker
angelegenheiten vier verletzt also wir
schnappen uns einen esslöffel und wir
machen sieben esslöffel schiers online
darauf brauchen wir jetzt ungefähr 400
milliliter flüssigkeit nimmt einfach
jeweils zwei milliliter also die von der
ungesicherten kokosmilch und 200
milliliter von normaler folglich dazu
gebe ich jetzt drei großzügige erster
für abend x8 ganz schön wir einfach
unsere flüssigkeit gemisch auf die skier
sagen so das würde ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen um
und die können sich schön über nacht im
kühlschrank voll saugen
jetzt können wir jetzt um die base von
unserer china wohl bereitet auch schon
mal vor ich morgen flügel papier
losfahren für die zunahme ist einfach
ein paar hin werden
dazu geben wir ein kleines stück wasser
damit sich das besser operieren lässt
und noch ein klein bisschen ergaben die
kraft um den bruch zwischen ein bisschen
nachzuhelfen
und wir geben einfach so eine schöne
baseline die gefrorenen mango stückchen
dass ich im kühlschrank einfach über
nacht aufbauen dann baue ich alles
zusammen und wir sehen uns jetzt zum
essen
[Musik]
mein lieber dann ist es auch schon
soweit für uns beide also ich glaube
jetzt ins tatsächlich ist das ganze auf
jeden fall dass wir haben hier einen kia
pudding also das sind quasi kasan die
ich über nacht quellen lassen habt in
kokosmilch und vollmilch also quasi
sondern cremige mädchen mischung und
polierte himbeere obendrauf frische
mangos er das ganze läuft so wir nehmen
uns beide ein löffel dann geht die
kamera aus und da musst du mich bewerten
von 1 bis 10 also ok heute dass auf
jeden fall im hinterkopf aber eine sache
die man eigentlich doch das sehr lecker
aber überlegt immer du würdest du das
machen du musst ja eigentlich schon am
abend davor dem frühstück vorbereiten
würde auch niemals wenn mir schon zu
viel von ihr sehen
so mag es ihrem aufgegessen bzw du bist
noch dabei wir ziehen trotzdem schon mal
das fazit ich bin sehr geschmeckt hat
ich fand das geisteskranken eishockey
recht jetzt bin ja wie du vorhin schon
gesagt das nicht so der frühstücks
schüler aber das war über das gleicht
also könnte ich mir morgens einziehen
war sehr frisch hat uns geschmeckt mit
diesem himberg kokos mäßigen so die
wache die konsistenz für dich von
pudding crossgate schritt dem ding mit
zehn gehendes trading ich finde ich
finds gut 40 jahren noch so wilde sachen
geplant ich glaube es wird ein sehr
guter tag für uns wir gehen jetzt erst
mal raus und drehen mit sebastian und
macht lambo und ihm ein heftiges videos
verlinkt auf jeden fall auch mal max
sowieso und wir sehen uns dann aber zum
mittagessen wieder so freunde kommen wir
zum mittagessen es gibt klassische
teenager wirklich einen top passt ich
habe die regeln karriere geholt und jede
menge spinat weil wir natürlich alle
wissen dass über riesige bäume spinat
sobald wir den in die pfanne geben so
klein wird da ist ein schnelles gericht
ist ein eigenes gedicht ich kann als
erstes an in dem ich den topf mit dem
nudelwasser aufsätze weil es geht so
schnell der platz von max gefallen ja
selbst ist eines der großen kopf aber
seine mama kommt relativ häufig
für jeden das heißt ich habe auf jeden
fall heute echte konkurrenz weil ich
habe hier das essen von der eigenen mam
heftigsten sebastian übrigens die jungs
haben gerade gedreht mit dem namenszug
rassig verlinkt euch das video wie
gesagt auch für eine neue folge
persönlicher corp neuer herd ich muss
jetzt irgend herausfinden kirchen
benutzer aber julio tut es mir natürlich
das wasser ordentlich beim geht ja auch
in carsten körnig und zwiebel und
knoblauch so unsere zwiebel würfeln die
ab 1
um das gleiche machen wir gleich mit
drei knoblauch unser ganzes magst du
gerne scharfes essen von vorwärts und
werden obwohl bisschen schwerer
und wir gehen nehmen die ganze tüte da
geht sind von textile aber glauben jeder
dies kann
anders als bei vapiano kann werde ich
kann ihren reihen das wird sehr gut und
garnelen braten schön durch von beiden
seiten auf rasch nach unseren atem
die bauern davon ungefähr 250 gramm also
die hälfte des mit so die garnelen sind
schön angebraten vielleicht wir geben
jetzt unsere zwiebeln in unseren
knoblauch mit in die pfanne aus
rietschen richtig lecker leuten ort wir
haben auch alle freuen sich hunger hat
gerade das frühstück heute morgen war ja
eher so kleinigkeit auch wenn es sehr
sehr lecker
ich bin absolut geile passt sagt sie
würde zu vergleichen weil die salz
pfeffer chili die tomaten wirklich
vielleicht gebe ich am ende noch drüber
bürger sollen aber nur glasig werden und
keine farbe zu kommen ich komme noch ein
bisschen wasser weil ich gleich ein
bisschen grün damit anrühre das gibt dem
ganzen noch ein bisschen mehr geschmack
und dann wird sich jetzt schon mal ein
bisschen drauf los und ich zitiere
mögen's alle gerne besser so leuchtet
sogar noch die sache perfekt und wann
wird es auch schon zeit für unsere sahne
ich habe es immer so prämien bevor eine
sehr reduzierte an
zu den gleichen job nicht gäbe die ganze
sache sind jetzt übrigens 250 milliliter
dann gebe ich jetzt noch einen guten
schluck von mpreis und wasser dazu und
ein teelöffel grüne funktioniert
gemüsebrühe superstition der verkauft
auch das ist nicht ganz 500 gramm weil
wir danach nochmals vorhaben so viel
kann ich schon mal sagen aber so 400
natürlich noch nicht vergessen ist muss
auch ein wenig terrain da ist auch
absolut perfekt passte in ordnung
kümmern und zwei teelöffel das wird eine
geschmacksfrage wirklich und wir geben
den salat spinat braucht man ruhig ein
bisschen überstehen r fällt sowieso
gleich zusammen
also ich war noch ein bisschen parmesan
dazu das bindet das ganze aber natürlich
kommt auch am ende gleich noch ein
bisschen kann man sagen so jetzt gehe
ich noch ganz schnell ein paar tomaten
dazu die sollen nur ein bisschen warm
werden
macht bei uns steht unser mittagessen ja
ich finde sie echt wirklich aus muss ich
das warten auf dem teller sie ist echt
gut aus und ich haben beide riesigen
ungarn schon wieder sebastian auch nach
vorne der freut sich aus dass er mit
essen kann ich von ihnen gesehen dass
die schmecken erste gabe du kannst den
spaß kann man geht einen schritt weiter
wir sehen uns gleich kleine
schweißausbruch war heiß war ich gekocht
hat das war mist aber ich glaube es hat
sich gelohnt was sagst du isst war
geistes komplett ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass es so gut schmeckte brecht jetzt
ehrlich was hörst du hast die
überplanung außergewöhnlich macht sie
auch bekommen ja eigentlich nicht
erinnerst du dich noch daran was hier
geschrieben hab einfach immer das mit
pastor und garnelen stimmt also ich
hatte gar nicht in wieder planen oder so
dann gedacht wo ich hoffe automatisch
werden ja aber ist war voll leid ich hab
das auch mal bei vapiano gästen üben und
ich habe das jetzt auch ohne die
erwartung gerade angefangen zu essen und
ich war dann positiv überrascht rechne
dachte er das projekt einst genauso also
es war echt geil
jetzt müssen wir nur noch sagen ein
bisschen was war das für dich also
geschmacklich würde ich echt ne 10 von
10 geben kraft ich würde nichts daran
ändern gar nicht wirklich einzige was
man vielleicht sagen könnte was aber
meckern auch von sehr hohem niveau ist
das vielleicht so ein bisschen zu tussi
war okay zu suchen ja also vielleicht
ein bisschen weniger so sehr über diesen
garnieren will sowas wirklich weiß was
du meinst weil ich habe ein bisschen
weniger zu machen weil das kommt erst
noch und dann war es ein bisschen viel
wo nach einer minimalen also man kann
sich hier sehen das jetzt auch nicht
mega fina aber ich würde auch nicht
funktionieren
wer fernsehen schauen sie da meckern auf
hohem niveau sei heute das abendessen
heute ist eigentlich mehr ein bisher
ich glaube danach muss man heute auch
nichts mehr essen und wir haben noch
drei stunden rückt bei uns ich will
sagen geschlagen direkt zur zubereitung
vom abendessen weiter geht's mit dem
abendessen ihr seht ich bin zu hause
also auch etwas was ich vorbereitet habe
es wird nämlich süß karotten kuchen ist
das stichwort beziehungsweise carrot
cake weil es immer besser klingt ich
weiß nicht sagt dass häufig aber es ist
eine
besten kuchen dies gibt was macht ein
cache richtig gut dass er richtig schön
saftig ist so schön aus und daran werden
jetzt arbeiten frauen auf jeden fall
wieder unsere rührmaschine
beziehungsweise in eine open nicht ihr
könnt es auch alles ohne eine machen von
hand gar kein problem unserer karotten
kuchen besteht aus zwei schichten
deshalb brauchen wir auch zwei solcher
formen und versierter für die unterseite
etwas backpapier zurechtschneiden ich
sage jetzt wieder einen perfekten kreis
mit dem boden unserer vormachen so wir
haben jetzt zwei faktor vier zuschnitte
die meisten seien ein zweites mal
zusammen mit dem die seite wo keiner
offenen enden sind und falten das
einfach zusammen
daneben ist von der mitte unserer form
bis zum rand und schneiden einfach hier
entlang
zwei perfekt geformte den boden bereiten
nehmen uns eine weitere schüssel zum
mixen kann unsere waage und geben durch
eine 320 gramm mehl dann kommt zu 230
gramm zucker dann 250 gramm feiner
zucker will man sehr gesunder kuchen
dazu geben jetzt zwei teelöffel zimt ist
jede menge also auch wenn zwei täter für
weg wird mir der schmeckt man auf jeden
fall dann kommt dazu ein großzügiger
teelöffel meersalz kleine halbe packung
backpulver das verbinden wir als mit dem
schneebesen ausrichten so unfassbar
lecker also alles schön verbunden
übrigens einfach meine geliebte blaue
schüssel verloren ich habe keine ahnung
wo sie ist falls du ein youtube spd
nicht gekocht habe ich habe sie bei dir
vergessen bitte sag mir bescheid ich
vermisse dich sehr
arbeiter in einer schüssel starten wir
uns einen tiefen teller in diese
schlagen wird fünf eier und die
verquirlen wird dazu gehen wir zwei
teelöffel vanille extrakt die röhren wir
auch unter das kann zu mischen wir
weiter und geben nach und nach 3 150
milliliter sonnenblumenöl
das weisen wir schon auf unseren
backofen auf 175 grad ober unterhitze an
und danken wir unseren schneebesen auf
die küchenmaschine wie gesagt ihr könnt
ihr ohne machen die meisten das ganze an
und wir gehen nach und da etwas von
unserer eigenen dem zug so lehnt das
alles schön verknetet wird kümmern wir
uns um die müllerin baumweg und gucken
dann stand mir jetzt einen beutel meine
sind 200 gramm nehmen uns so eine
handvoll raus weil ich später zum
dekorieren brauchen und die
rechtsprüfung hier mit einem nudelholz
so soll übrigens die konsistenz von
unserem dann nehmen wir uns jetzt unsere
walnüsse und geben sie einfach dazu und
halten das jetzt unter unserem tag und
ich sage euch leute ist nicht so
unglaublich lecker wirklich hab gerade
kurz vergessen die kamera zu stellen
aber ich habe einfach den teig auf die
beiden springform gleichmäßig aufgeteilt
der wagen ist auf 175 grad vorgeheizt
jetzt geht unsere beiden formen auf
einen rasch den ruf ein und wir warten
jetzt pickt sich einmal mit einem
zahnstocher hinein und er bleibt nichts
dran kleben das heißt er ist fertig und
der andere braucht allerdings noch ein
bisschen sie denn mal hoch hat ein
bisschen weniger hitze ab bekommen wir
klopfen wir also fünf minuten dann
kümmern wir uns jetzt auch in unser eis
hinnehmen so ungefähr ein halbtax
frischkäse gramm sind das so etwa 260
gramm den frischkäse reden wir schon mal
prämie dann nehmen wir uns so eine
gesamte paket 250 gramm puderzucker und
möchten das mitunter dem ganzen spiel
mit nach 90 meter schlagzeilen zu wort
wir unser rising wenn das ganze mit
frischhaltefolie zugedeckt ist geben wir
es in den kühlschrank so wenn unser
kuchen gekühlt ist können wir auch
unsere springform öffnen und in kuba auf
einer woche zum kühlen
10 das backpapier abschuss und so lassen
wir beide kuchen jetzt komplett
auskühlen unserer kunden ist jetzt
komplett abgekühlt und wir schneiden das
jetzt ganz eben weil ihr seht vielleicht
da ist noch minimaler hobel 3 hier
starten wir ganz einfach weil der kuchen
aufeinander und deshalb muss das tier
neben sein wenn das herz so schön eben
ist schlaf wir uns unser hosting und
geben es in die mitte unseres kuchens
gesagt ungefähr die hälfte verteilt sie
wissen schon mal wäre etwa so viel drauf
ist geben wir die zweite schicht von
unsere kuchen dazu und wir drücken und
das ganze an ihr seht schon das frosting
rutscht jetzt nach außen an allen ecken
und enden können natürlich auch noch ein
bisschen nachhelfen wenn dann ein zwei
stellen es zu wenig war und den rest von
eissing geben wir jetzt einfach oben auf
dem kuchen drauf so sieht das ganze
auswärts fertig ist der als bisher
probiert habe beim bummeln und auch lara
richtig lecker kochen wir oben braucht
noch ein paar buy -liste und wir haben
eine fetten geilen carrot cake
[Musik]
ich glaube danach wirklich kann man es
kaum gegeben weil hier das ding ist ich
habe das noch nie gegessen ok karotten
gucken so deswegen ist kann dass man
sich jetzt nicht mega bewerten also du
kannst du sagen willst es kann ja auch
einfach sagen dass mir karosserie steckt
da sein kollege mit zehn von zehn ist
aber das ist halt einfach nicht kennen
das vollkommen in ordnung also ist
einfach sagen wie es geschmeckt und ich
musste mir deutlich auf karotten kuchen
das klingt erstmal nicht so geil aber
das ist nicht wahr
also die wahren meister sind wir schon
mal hier leute dementsprechend konnte
ich dich wollen wir gucken überzeugen
ich fand's lecker ja extrem ist ich
würde es mir denke ich jetzt nicht zum
restaurant bestellen
okay ich bin also jemand der teilweise
schokoladen als als nachtisch wird er
auch mäßig geil aber extrem lecker so
weihnachtsmusik mit dem zukauf passt gut
zur jahreszeit viel geschwitzt aber
jeden fall hat ja ich kann das jetzt
nicht mega kaste werten weil jetzt der
erste karten möhren kuchen ist gegessen
haben aber auch ein von weniger fand ich
sehr nah es war schön juicy zu luftig
die konsistenz
die bahn müsste obendrauf fand ich sehr
gut und die autorin funktioniert
vielleicht nämlich unerfahren als koch
aber ich muss man das machen so ich bin
ich bin sehr dankbar
der kriegt auch von mir schnitt 10 von
10 c ich mag halt carry trade kunden
gerne richtig gut wirklich macht den
unbedingt nach es war extrem lecker
macht danke die regale werden
danke für deine gastfreundschaft und das
ist ja sehr gerne
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
macht's gut bis sein und schauen